le gaz est plus particulièrement le prix
du gaz fait l'actualité ces dernières
semaines en effet son prix culmine à des
sommets encore jamais atteint et se
répercute sur les factures des ménages
en france et dans le reste de l'europe
avec la mise en service prochaine du
gazoduc north stream 2 enfin terminée
après des délais causés par les
sanctions américaines il existait un
espoir en effet on peut penser que
l'arrivée d'une nouvelle source
d'approvisionnement massif en gaz allait
provoquer une baisse mécanique des prix
d'autant que le gaz russe est meilleur
marché que le gaz liquéfié acheminé par
bateau depuis les etats unis mais il
manque encore des certifications à
obtenir auprès du régulateur allemand de
l'énergie une procédure entamée le 8
septembre qui pourrait tarder au total
jusqu'à quatre mois
la certification du 'pipeline' pour
autant que je sache sera si tardive
qu'elle ne pourra probablement pas nous
aider cet hiver
pour répondre à la demande en énergie et
s'assurer d'un prix fixe sur le long
terme budapest a choisi de se fournir en
gaz russe un contrat prévoyant la
livraison de 4 5 milliards de mètres
cubes de gaz sur une durée de 15 ans a
été signé le gaz arrivant jusqu'en
hongrie transite désormais via le
gazoduc nord stream qui passe ensuite
par la bulgarie et la serbie et non plus
par l'ukraine comme cela était le cas
lors du précédent contrat ce qui a le
don de provoquer la colère de kiev
transporter du gaz en contournant
l'ukraine sap la sécurité énergétique de
notre pays et celle de l'europe
en conséquence kiev a demandé
l'imposition de sanctions soient quoi
moscou a répondu que l'ukraine n'avait
pas le droit de s'ingérer dans les
relations entre la russie et la hongrie
en effet l'ukraine vont affaiblir le
débit de gaz qui transite dans ses
gazoducs entre turk stream au sud et le
lancement prochain de nord stream 2 au
nord les finances de kiev qui dépendent
beaucoup des taxes sur le transit s'en
ressentent on l'aura compris la hausse
des prix tant le marché du gaz en
particulier en europe et la russie en
tant qu'important fournisseur est pointé
du doigt ainsi 40 eurodéputés en
particulier de pays d'europe centrale et
orientale ont réclamé à la commission
l'ouverture d'une enquête sur
l'explosion des tarifs de gaz moscou
estime de son côté pouvoir exporter son
gaz comme il le souhaite il y a eu et il
y aura des accusations contre la russie
qui sont en majorité politisé
entre le redémarrage des économies à
travers le monde le faible taux de
remplissage des réserves de gaz
européenne ou encore l'augmentation des
prix des quotas d'émission de co2 en
europe ses droits à polluer qui favorise
la consommation de gaz au détriment du
charbon les causes de cette hausse des
prix sont nombreuses et interconnectés
quand des tensions diplomatiques
viennent s'y ajouter la russie pourrait
bien faire office de bouc émissaire
idéal mais la réalité est quelque peu
plus complexe